for someone who lives outside of the
united kingdom the terms united kingdom
and great britain and england often feel
interchangeable and they feel like
they're referring to the same thing but
as we'll see in this video they aren't
referring to exactly the same thing
so the united kingdom is actually short
for the united kingdom of great britain
and northern ireland so the united
kingdom includes everything here on the
right on the island of great britain so
it includes all of that
and it includes part of the island of
ireland it includes northern ireland
right over there that is the united
kingdom the united kingdom of great
britain and northern ireland
now
what are they talking about when these
people say great britain well they're
just referring to the large island here
on the right and what about england well
england is a subset of great britain
england is this region in this peachy
color right over here on the island
on the island of
great britain
now the reason why some people will
interchange these words is because
london is in england it's the seed of
power for the united kingdom but there
are other regions and some people would
even say nations because the folks in
these regions historically have shared
common traditions and common dialects
sometimes bordering on common language
and the other regions or you could even
see say nations of people who have a
common affinity include the welsh and so
they are in wales also part of great
britain which is part of the united
kingdom you have the scots
also
or the people who live in scotland also
part of great britain which is part of
the united kingdom
so that's great britain and as we said
the united kingdom is the united kingdom
of great britain and northern ireland so
it also includes this it includes this
northern part right over here of the
island of ireland and so some of you
might be saying well what is
right here in green what is the rest of
the island of ireland well that is the
republic
the republic
of
the republic of ireland
so hopefully that clarifies a little bit
the difference between the united
kingdom which includes
wales england scotland and northern
ireland it's the united kingdom of great
britain and northern ireland the
difference between that great britain
which is the the large island here on
the right england which is a part of
great britain and the republic of
ireland which we just talked about